- Hello, teachers, I'm Sal Khan,
founder of the
not-for-profit Khan Academy,
with the goal of helping you
accelerate outcomes in your classroom.
And I have an exciting announcement.
What we're launching is a new
mastery framework on Khan Academy.
We have some of the most
significant features ever
around personalization
and mastery learning,
where your students can get
as much practice as they need,
as much feedback as they
need, and the most important
part of a mastery learning
system is the teacher,
is the human being in the classroom.
So it's explicitly designed to
increase human interactions,
to give you, the teacher,
insights on which students
might need help, which students might need
a little bit of motivation.
We've designed dashboards so
that teachers can identify
gaps and misconceptions in
their students in real time.
We've significantly added
to the amount of content,
not just in math, where we've
always had tens of thousands
of exercises from
kindergarten through calculus
and statistics, but also in
high school and college-level
sciences and the humanities.
And, most importantly, it's
flexible to meet your needs.
This can be done in the
classroom, it could be used
as part of in-class practice,
it could be part of review,
or it can be done as part of homework.
And we are seeing the
classrooms that use Khan Academy
for the classroom, at
least 30 minutes per week,
are seeing incredible gains
in their student outcomes.
- I look at my reports a lot.
I use data a lot to drive my instruction
and to drive what I need to reteach.
- They tell me exactly
where that student is.
It tells me how many
attempts that they have done
and specifically, so there's
real data telling me,
hey, this student is getting it wrong.
- They're not doing 30 problems
and then realizing, uh,
I don't know what I'm
doing and I just made
some really bad habits for myself.
- So thank you, teachers.
All of us at Khan Academy
are incredibly inspired
by the work that you
do day in and day out.
Anything we can do to
make your lives easier
or to help accelerate the
learning for your students,
we are excited to do with you.
(upbeat music)